In this problem and the next we’re going to build
a large portion of our javascript, parser. In
particular, we’re first going to focus on
javascript statements and then make it even
easier really only go and consider six type
statements. If then, so if you have an If
statement basically, if then else, so here
we’re going to handle a javascript statement,
something like this and then also an else. Whereas
this first type of statement is just this portion
whereas the if and else handles all of this.
We’re going to also do assignment, so variable X
equals a five. Return statements, an example of
that in javascript will look like this where we
have the return keyword followed by an expression
. Here I just have five. We have two ones left.
One involving decoration namely using the
var keyword, so this declares a variable X and so
it’s a five versus just setting at the five later
on. And the last type we’re going to handle in
this portion is just the existence of an
expression. You can have in your javascript
an expression in the middle of your code
. So instead of stuff here, we could just
say five. This doesn’t do anything, but
it’s a number five and its valid javascript.
So this is pretty straightforward if you just follow
the rules that were given at the top of the program
and we’re going to go straight to the IDE and work
through it one by one. So here I have my interpreter
ready for us to get started with this question.
So here I have the rule for a function and we’re
going to write this out. Here I’m telling the
parser that this is going to be a parser for the
element non-terminal and I’m going to call this
one the function parser. The first when to thing is
going to be a string that tells a parser apply this
rule. So here I say an element can go to the
terminal function and identifier the
some optional fantasies are right
followed by a compound sequences statements.
And once this has been matched, I’m going to apply
it such that element is going to be the tuple
with the world function. The name of the function
, which is going to be identifier, the optional
parameters which is number four and then six is
going to be the compound statements. An
can also just be a statement,
which is going to be some sort of statement
followed by a The two poles that
it matches is going to be the word statement
and the contents of that statement.
Here I had my two rules for optional parameters
and as the name implies the parameters can
be optional, so our params can go to nothing
or it can be a sequence of parameters. Now
parameters can be some kind of identifier
followed by a coma and more parameters or
it can be one or the last parameter is just
going to be an identifier. Notice how I put
the identifier in a list because parameters
are always a list even if there is just one thing
in them. A compound statement is a sequence
of statements in between a left brace and a
right brace. the rules for statements,
statements can be empty, so you can have nothing
in your – between your left and right braces
or it can be a single statement and a
followed by more statements.
So now we’re going to define the statements.
Let’s start with F. If we do have an F statement,
we’re going to put it in a tuple in our parse
street where the first entry in the tuple is the
string, if then it indicate that it’s an F
statement. The second one is going to be
the expression of the F statement and the
last element of our tuple are going to be
the compound statements that comprise the
then. In the if then else , we have very similar
structure except we’ve also added an else,
which is going to be an additional entry in
our tuple that is the sequence of statements
that you do if the expression is not
evaluated to be true.
Here we have assignment. It’s going to an
identifier. It’s a X equals the equal sign and
then some expressions if I and then on parser
you’re going to put a sign, the identifier and
then expression to which the identifier is set.
For return, we’re just going to do return
and then the expression that we’re returning.
We use the keyword bar to declare
instead a variable, so we’re going to have
the keywords bar followed by an identifier,
the equal sign and expression we want
to put bar, the identifier and expression.
So make this a little more concrete,
it would be as if we were doing this and the tuple
that we put in our Pastry is going to be bar, X, five.
And lastly we say a statement to an expression,
which we haven’t defined yet and we’re saving
for the next problem. Taken altogether we
have much of our javascript parser. Well,
at the least the part, that handles statements.